The Man Who was a Dwarf and Later a Giant
The man was Adam Rainer born in Graz, Austria
sometime in 1899 (the exact date isn’t known).
Rainer’s parents were neither tall nor short
for the time, with his father measuring in
at 5 feet 8 inches (1.72 m) and his mother
at 5 feet 5 inches (1.65 m).
He even had a brother who matched his father’s
height at 5 feet 8 inches.
This wasn’t the case for Adam.
Thanks to the fact that Adam attempted to
join the army when he was 18 to participate
in WWI, we know that at that age Rainer had
reached a height of just 4 feet 6.3 inches
(1.38 m), and then at 19 he measured in at
4 feet 8.3 inches (1.43 m) when he tried to
join up again.
Both times he was considered too short and
also too weak to be able to join the military.
For reference, the cutoff for someone being
classified as a dwarf is usually considered
to be an adult height of less than 4 feet
10 inches (1.47 m).
While he was short, according to the medical
report, he actually had exceptionally large
feet for his height, with his shoes measuring
in at a European size of 43 at the age of
18, which is about a size 10 in U.S. sizes.
According to Rainier by the time he hit 21,
while still barely
classified as a dwarf in height, his shoe
size had gone up to a European size 53, which
would be about a size 20 in the U.S. (for
reference, Shaquille O’Neal wears a size
22-23).
Although his feet were continuing to grow
at a remarkable pace, Rainer himself was staying
at more or less the same height.
That’s when something even more bizarre
than his clown-feet happened.
For a reason unknown at the time, Adam started
growing again… rapidly.
What must have initially seemed a blessing
to the short Rainer, soon turned into a curse.
From his 21st birthday to his 32nd, Rainer
grew from just under 4 feet 10 inches tall
to 7 feet 2 inches tall (1.47 m to 2.18 m).
It should also be noted that his height would
have been greater than this, except by his
26th birthday he started developing a severe
spinal curve, which continued to progress
as he grew.
This, and later difficulty in eating, had
the negative side effect of leaving Rainer
bed ridden for the majority of the latter
half of his life.
If that wasn’t bad enough, he also went
blind in his right eye and his vision diminished
in his left.
His hearing also started to go and he became
deaf in his left ear.
So what caused this extreme shift in height?
After a medical exam done by Doctors F. Windholz
and A. Mandl, they discovered a tumor on his
pituitary gland, which not only explained
his rapid growth but his partial blindness
as well.
As far as the growth is concerned, this tumor
resulted in a condition known as acromegaly,
where the pituitary gland produces excessive
amounts of growth hormone during adulthood.
His vision loss was due to the compression
of his optic chiasm, which is where the right
and left eye nerves cross near the pituitary
gland.
To try to fix the problem, in 1930 doctors
removed the tumor, but he still continued
to grow, albeit at a much slower rate that
seemed even slower than it was because of
his spinal curvature continuing to increase.
For instance, from December 1930 to May of
1931, his standing height stayed the same,
but his spinal curvature increased.
Over the next and final 19 years of his life,
Rainer’s spinal curve would continue to
increase and he’d grow another 6 inches,
dying at the age of 51 in 1950 at a height
of about 7 feet 8 inches (2.34 m), making
him the only known person to spend time officially
classified as a dwarf and then as a giant.
Bonus Fact:
• The word “giant” ultimately derives
from the name of a Greek mythological race
of giants defeated by the gods, with the help
of Heracles, when the giants tried to free
the Titans.
This race were called “gigas” and were
the children of Gaia and Uranus.
They were produced when Kronus castrated Uranus,
with Uranus’ blood fertilizing Gaia.
Once the giants were defeated, they were buried
deep underground to imprison them.
According to Greek mythology, earthquakes
and volcanic eruptions are caused by the race
of giants struggling to free themselves from
the depths of the Earth.
The Greek word “gigas” evolved into the
English word “giant” via Latin and then
the Old French “geant”, which by 1350
had been adopted into English as “giant”.
It was first used to describe a person who
is exceptionally tall in 1559 and before that
simply as an adjective to describe some attribute
that a person had that was exceptional.